and my tendency is when i feel good i'm
so extreme
like i'm too extreme i have a problem
like i
do the name of this podcast is called
pretty pretty so i get it i
get it there are times when i'd be
worthy of that title i'll wake up on a
saturday and i'll be like i'm so glad
i've got the whole day free like
because the last five days will have
been in sunny and i'll be like i've got
the whole weekend i'm just
i'm not gonna plan anything and then
i'll be
like i kind of feel like training today
i'm gonna go train today and all that
same day call up a trainer and i'll be
like
that very same day yeah you're so
excited that you have the same day time
off
probably an hour later i'll be like do
you have any training so
yeah okay i booked that at five o'clock
maybe i should like go on a hike
yeah and then i'll be a nice relaxing
afternoon you know what i'm gonna clear
out the garage
i've been meaning to do that and then
before i know it i have booked a
like this manic day
and i this kind of sounds like something
i might do
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
i'm really excited about today's episode
with matthew hussey
or matt let's just call him matt um for
casual uh we had a
really cool conversation and it was one
of these really interesting episodes
where
i i know has worked so well and he is
an expert in the realm of relationships
and i just kept thinking to myself what
am i going to ask him and where am i
going to go with this
and he has just again just such a giant
scope when it comes to that area of
expertise
and before the episode i just thought
you know what i'm just gonna like let
this free flow and it ended up being the
perfect thing because
he's in his own sort of transition
and alchemy of message
um so we had like a really cool
conversation that i don't think that is
gonna be
something that is there's not a lot of
it out there
um but you're going to hear that
relatability that maybe
you yourself are going through where
it's like hey like things are changing
and or maybe things are going to change
or
hey i heard your i heard the things that
are going on in your life and i
feel similar maybe i'm about ready for a
transition
so we had a great conversation um and i
hope you leave
feeling inspired and prepared to step
into whatever it is that life is calling
you to
it seems like because in hearing about
your family and hearing about
having a good relationship that that is
probably why you can speak about
relationships is because you have a good
one with your family
i think there's some truth to that uh
there's christopher hitchens who is a
journalist and a writer he
he actually said one of the big
tragedies
is that relationship wisdom doesn't get
is
isn't inherited it doesn't get passed
down through the genes
and therefore you can have plenty of
people who
come from families with good marriages
or whose who witness their parents make
horrible mistakes
but don't necessarily learn from those
mistakes
uh because you there are some mistakes
you have to make yourself or you don't
truly realize the pain of them
unless you make them yourself and of
course having a
parents with a great marriage is no
guarantee that you won't make poor
decisions so
but i will say this i grew up with
a ton of love and that helps
i think if you're really loved and
you're
shown what love looks like because your
love sounds like these birds right now
they're going crazy it's very idyllic
i'm expecting some sort of fairies to
start jumping around
and i it's very sort of ancient
it's very greek myth around us right now
i um i think when you have
a tremendous amount of love and that
love because you could go through bad
times
you could go through you know bankruptcy
or financial hardship
and you're gonna have a struggle growing
up but if you still have love
throughout that struggle that i think is
one of the greatest securities you can
benefit from
okay but describe that love because i
think love can come in lots of different
forms like love comes through
um you know
various attachments um through
codependency through all kinds of things
so like
when you say love though like what is
the idealistic
sort of hope that you'd grow up with if
you were to describe
love well my
my you know it's in my family
there's a good deal of healthy love and
then there's sort of me going home even
now and my mum
trying to stuff cake and sandwiches down
my face wait that's not love
that that might be more codependent i i
you know she needs me so i feel good my
mom needs me to need a sandwich
i uh i still there's a few of those
remnants when i go home there's you know
my mom
like trying to feed me and if i'm i say
no she's like oh go on
you know and i know in that moment
having a sandwich equates to
you still needs something from me and of
course i have to continue to remind my
mum i need you for more than sandwiches
you know your actual love is the thing
that i could never really or would never
want to live without
but i so i do think there are all sorts
of
yeah there are their love is often
masked by
those things those the ways people
suffocate each other when they don't
have enough purpose in their own life
and when they're trying to figure out
what they're about or we just get
validated from how we get love
you know i i but i do in my family the
one thing i was always very blessed with
was
if whatever i wanted to do even if it
was uncomfortable for the people that
loved me
if they truly thought it was best for me
they wanted me to do it
like me coming to america was one of the
hardest things
in my life which is why i could never
truly
tell myself i was moving to america i
came here originally because there was a
tv show i did
and even then i told myself three months
let's just see
you know but i was excited by the notion
of coming and being here
but i never really committed to the idea
of
living here i always told myself even
today i sort of tell myself
you know we'll see i'm enjoying it here
right now
we'll see um but my parents undoubtedly
it must have been
incredibly difficult for them and my
brothers for me to come here
i thought you said it was difficult for
you or was it for everybody
yeah both because we're so close we are
a very very close family
but it speaks to the love that that is
pure that's there that
they would never have said to me you're
leaving us
like why they if this is good for you
go and do it and my family is very much
like that with each other
it kind of reminds me because i lived in
england for three years when i
uh was 16 to 19 racing and it was
hard but they said i can't imagine you
it would be even worse if you didn't
have the opportunity
so while you know my mom cried at night
and or
you know i think i don't know um but um
so i heard but you know they were sad
that i was gone but they
couldn't have imagined that i it would
be worse to not have the opportunity and
so it sounds similar is that
worse that you didn't have the
opportunity it doesn't mean it's not
hard though
no very diff i mean every a lot of
choices i've made have been difficult
for my
my family i my dad was very
entrepreneurial but that came with its
ups and downs when i was a kid and
my mum definitely felt those ups and
downs
so when i came out of university and
immediately
instead of going and getting a job i
slept on an office floor
and said you know i'm going to start a
business
i had this little tiny office in london
it was like a loft
an attic in a building in london and i
would sleep on the floor in that in that
office and i remember
thinking i was impressing my mum
actually i remember inviting her up one
day
to london to be like look at my office
space and
she came in and she saw the sleeping bag
on the floor
and i didn't realize until years later
this was only a few
couple of years ago she
went home that night and cried to my dad
and i never knew that at the time
yeah i think it was too close to home
for her
that like you know we put you you know
we went through
all of these ups and downs and and and
now
instead of going and taking a job and
having a steady path
you're repeating this wild
entrepreneurial life of
you know we'd gone bankrupt when i was a
kid a couple of times and we got moved
from a nice house to a trailer and
like so it i think from my mum it was
too like
why why do you need to like can't you
just go and
it's not like i was even doing something
that sounded promising when i was 21 i
was
starting a company that was helping
women in their dating lives so
my mom was like this this can't be the
fit like this isn't going to be the
thing that's
you know you're on a in a sleeping bag
in an office like
showering in a sink like this can't be
the
sharing thing's pretty normal in england
in the winter i will tell you it gets i
mean i feel
chilly stay in places where there's only
a bath and then i have to like
which is essentially a big sink yeah
right exactly what i'm saying and i like
had to i
literally poured a cup over my head
well don't make it sound that medieval
but there are some places that are
places
very charles dickens i i was racing
i was at racetracks in the middle of
nowhere and i'm sure that had to do with
it but
probably um so the first your first job
was then because i'm like super curious
how you got to the point of being able
to have such
wisdom and perspective on relationships
um but you said your first job was
teaching
women no well my first job was at 13 i
was a pop boy in my dad's night club
i was like oh my god this is how you can
teach it you've been like
always been on the scene forever i
suppose
i didn't see much worth replicating in
that environment though
you also learn by things that you don't
want
by learning what you don't want you know
what you do want i think the biggest
thing i learned in a
nightclub was why not to drink i
that was the key takeaway there is i
just saw people on their worst behavior
night after night
but i went on to dj from i was
my dad was a dj and i went on to
11 years old i bought my first pair of
decks and i started djing in
in this nightclub at 14 and i was a late
bloomer anyway so i was tiny
i think my first experience with
relationships was negotiating
the world of adults and you know
bouncers that were
these what to me they were titans you
know and
the the kind of clientele that would
come and
you know threatened to punch me if i
didn't play their song or
like i was i i was very much in a world
of
smoke and beer and adults and learning
how to negotiate
for i was 14 when i started playing a
warm-up set
in the in the club that's about when
they start letting you in the clubs in
england at about 14 anyway that's not
far off
it's not because i'm pretty sure that i
did that yeah yeah it could be quite
early but i
i just when i was when i was like 11
years old i
my dad whether things were going well
for us or not he always had books he was
my dad really lorded the value of books
and wherever we were whether we were in
a
you know a makeshift trailer situation
trying to get back on our feet or
whether we were in a
house he always had a bookshelf and
there was always self-development on
those shelves and i was
11 years old when i picked up how to win
friends and influence people from my
dad's bookshelf
yeah and and even then i picked it up
because
half because i was thought the title you
know
how ridiculous is this what that someone
would need to win friends and influence
people and yet the other half of me was
like i really want to learn what so
yeah i was kind of thinking it seems
like something you'd want to know
well at 11 it's a bit of a weird move i
but i
i picked it up and i immediately was
hooked
i the idea that
it was a revolutionary idea to me at the
time
that you can be better
in with people and the way you come
across
and the impact you make that i was a shy
kid
and the idea that you weren't condemned
to your current level of confidence
to your current level of ability with
people
to your current level of charisma even
though i wouldn't have articulated it
that way at the time
i remember it being this like
this discovery to me by the way i didn't
know
that how to win friends and influence
people was a known book
i thought i discovered some kind of
secret scroll
that you know like you were in egypt
recently like you felt you found a
scroll in a part of the
the temple or the pyramid that no one
had seen
like that's how i felt about that book i
was like no one knows about this like
i've got all these abilities now this
book
little did i know it was a scenario a
secret maybe self development classic no
i used to i remember actually
specifically a girl making fun of me at
school
because i was reading it in a in like a
break moment oh
got it and someone being like what are
you read like why are you reading that
but i i genuinely was was hooked and
that
the reason i mention it is because when
i went into djing and every other job
after that
it what i learned there and in
subsequent
books and what that set me on a path of
was valuable to me in everything i did
it was the most transferable skill set
i'd ever learned and there was no part
of my life whether it
whether it was getting a crowd whipped
up into a frenzy from a dj stand
or coaching someone one-to-one
or giving a speech to
a theater of people in my work now
it was it was all born out of the same
set of skills and i've just been
refining them ever since
and of course trying alongside that to
learn
to be happy because those two aren't the
same thing
uh this the competence of having impact
and
being skilled with people and knowing
how to articulate a point or an idea to
get it across
or break both of those down so let's not
forget about the be happy thing yeah
so then what was it from the book that
like what's the takeaway if you were to
say this is how
i i mean i think in the beginning i just
would go and use that book
i would practice on teachers at school
practice what though
it could be anything from listening
better
to noticing something about them instead
of making it all about me
to um showing
you know when someone was arguing with
me about something
starting by understanding their point of
view before
talking about my own showing that they
i've really understood them first
it was all the basic stuff you know this
that book is
that book is timeless because it's
fundamental not because it's
revolutionary
that's the great joke of it all and i'm
sure if i reread that book today
that there would be things in there that
i've stopped doing
that i'd go why did i stop doing that
because that's the thing about the
fundamentals they are the easiest thing
to stop doing especially when you think
you've
gotten good at something you know we
through different phases of our lives we
we do forget certain fundamental things
i mean how why is it that
sometimes we could feel i was happier at
21 than i was at 31 because
maybe at 21 there was something
different about your life we could go on
to achieve a lot
and that can detach us from certain
truths
certain fundamentals we can achieve a
lot and suddenly the world makes it all
about us
you know the world keeps asking you
questions about yourself and now you
become a worse listener not
because you chose consciously to become
a worse listener but because for a long
time
now you've been told it's all about you
or you've been
every interview is about you so now you
find yourself at a random dinner table
expecting that you're gonna talk about
like the most interesting thing is
you're talking about you when actually
if you go back to what you knew at 15 or
18 or 21 it's
let's make them the star at this dinner
table but i think it's easy to
but all the basics are very easy to
forget which is why i don't
the date the biggest danger of the way
we live right now the greatest
opportunity is the availability of
information right
totally it's also the greatest danger
because
we have so many voices so many experts
so many podcasts so many videos so many
of
everything that
we can get lost in a sea of advice
and forget that there's like five things
okay what are they you're great at lists
i mean like you're going to look like
that you're like the five things the
three things the ten things yeah well
that's easy in an edited video
i was when i'm i was on the today show
and i
literally said to kathie lee and hoda
they said to me matt what do you think
about whatever the question was
i know well kathy lee and hoda there's
really three
things you have to remember about that i
learned there and then
never on live tv give a number
for how many things you're going to say
because that commits you
to remembering those three things which
i didn't
i got to the end of the first one and
then i said
number two and i realized i no longer
knew what number two was
wow and i i literally said i i i
i forgot what number two was and kathy
and hoda looked at me and she went
i could see that you forgot and here was
what i did
thinking this was clever i went no no i
got it
number two now i thought that by saying
that
i would remember that somehow in me
saying
like i've got it i would buy myself a
moment to then have it
i still didn't have it so then i got i
got to the end of that sentence and went
yeah i uh i still i still don't remember
and she goes
let's move on perfect what are some
fundamentals that you do like
every day like today tomorrow like in
your daily activity that are so
ingrained in you
from reading that book and from practice
and that what are what are some of them
that you're trying to implement so like
what's established what's
what's subconscious programming and what
is trying
what is in the conscious mind that
you're trying to integrate
i think so from that book i think i
think about it less and less in a sense
because
a lot of like coming here and doing a
podcast
is is home
in a way right like that's
i'm i you could put me on stage and say
matt the audience is just gonna fire
questions at you and i
you know on live tv whenever you go on
tv the producers always come to you and
they say
here's the questions that people are
going to ask you and i'm like i don't i
don't want to
even tell me there if you want it makes
no difference to me i'm
the same in fact don't ask me because
i'd rather not know because
the most spontaneous answer right feels
nicer
which also speaks though to the fact
that you've built that skill set
you know over time whether consciously
and directly or whether it's just
because the amount you've been exposed
to the limelight
you've built that i so
for me i don't think as much about that
i do think i'm always looking to refine
like i'm
we can talk about that differently but
i'm always looking at things in my
speech for example
now one of the things i really think
about a lot is
did i use too many words to say that
you know instead of thinking you start
out in public speaking and you're
constantly
in the mood in the mode of have i got
enough to say that's always the fear how
am i gonna fill all the time right you
know
now i'm the reverse because that's never
that's not been a problem for me for
years
so now i think do am i am i
using up too much time to say what i
need to say can i say it quicker more
efficiently can i say it better
but aside from those tweaks i think more
these days
about the the fundamentals for me these
days are what are the things
i need to do each day
to be happy and to bring my best
to my life and to the people around me
because i don't think it's all about my
happy i'm not
i'm actually not one of these people
that thinks the goal is to be happy all
the time
um i i i don't
i think we have an obsession with being
happy and
the i whilst i think that
experiencing happiness i think firstly
happiness is a cloudy concept
there's different versions of happiness
a lot of people equate happiness to
pleasure
and those two things aren't the same
thing like someone recently said to me
because i was complaining about you know
a stressful day
and they were saying to me it should be
fun
and i was like really like where did you
get
that idea i just don't agree like
when someone says something like that to
me i'm like sometimes
like this is this is fun but good
this is but this is different this is
not me like
like laboring over my my book this
morning or trying like
like trying to like how does this that's
tough
like i'm sure being a race car driver
was always fun
right challenging totally you know you
do it
a lot and there's a kind of quiet
fulfillment that comes from doing hard
things those aren't the same as
fun that's exactly right they i remember
my last race then it was
the andy 500 and somebody said are you
having so
are you having fun and i was like fun i
was like
fun is being drunk i was like i'm out
there at 2
40. hoping that i keep it on the track
i'm like no it's not
fun but it can definitely be rewarding
like it can in
sort of in a different way but it's not
i wouldn't say it's
fun and so i totally yeah exactly so i i
i really i really want to bring
my best self to my life you know whether
it's to
my family my friends my work and to
myself
and i i do more than
ever in the last few years i
am more more aware that being
happier being less stressed
is a version of energy that allows you
to bring more
to your life and so i find myself
increasingly
i and by the way i'm still figuring this
out so
this is not i'm not coming to you about
this from a place of like here's
you know everything you don't have all
the answers that's why you're here today
come on
definitely don't have all the answers i
i'm here for your story
i really i've been someone in my life
who has been used to saying yes
to a lot of things and is
has consistently overestimated the
amount i can do
the amount of things that i can cram
into a day or a week or a month
and consistently leaves myself with
uh an enormous to-do list that's
unfinished at the end of every day
because of the amount that i load on
and the effects of that i i think are
not good
you know i think that whilst you you can
still achieve it
an incredible amount that way but
it doesn't leave me feeling great
because you're always looking at this
list that you didn't get to
you're always looking at what you didn't
do and you could have done brilliant
things
but while everyone else is saying look
at what you've done you're going but
look at what i didn't do
and so i that was my tendency for a long
time
i'm saying all of this because when you
ask me what are the fundamentals
today i i
look at my day and i try to
get out of the old habits i have
of waking up stressed before the day has
even begun
because i'm anticipating everything that
i'm gonna have to do today
that i decided right no one came down
from on high and said matt this is
everything you have to do today
even if it's my staff or my like people
around me or whatever saying but we need
this from you and that from you and that
from you
i did that i created that they didn't
appear out of nowhere
i built a business i had like so i've
created all these demands on my time
and then i add my own to it as well and
so
i i try to have a simplicity about the
way i view my day now
where i say there's only a handful of
quite simple things that need to happen
for me to have a great day
it's not this crazy schedule and this
that
there's a few things that need to happen
one i need to do
like two great hours of work
great and by that i don't mean that's
how long i'll be working today
because anyone who runs a company and
does knows that you
work a lot longer than that but most of
the time we
say we're working we're kind of working
it's true right it's like the kid who's
like
at college and they're like i've just
been in the library
studying for the last 11 hours you're
like
no you haven't we're on social media
you've been studying for like
three maybe two yeah you have not been
studying in the library for the last 11
hours
right um we don't have that much
in us you know energy-wise yeah our
cognitive bandwidth is not going to
allow us to do that so we
only have a couple of i truly believe
and i think neuroscience
uh uh confirms this in in some form that
we only have a couple of like really
great hours in us a day
and using them wisely is
one of the fundamentals to me that if
i'm currently writing a book or if i'm
trying to make something special
those couple of hours need to be focused
on that
very cognitively demanding task
if i lose them i never quite get them
back you know if it gets to 4 pm and i
still haven't
done that thing right the chances of me
getting that back are slim
and i won't have that good feeling that
comes
that sort of stays for a lot of the day
when i wake up and do something
difficult
and then for the rest of the day i have
that like i really believe when people
say you sh
like enjoy the process when it comes to
like the gym
fine if you can learn to enjoy the gym
that's awesome that's a good thing
but but that's not necessarily why you
go
you go to the gym for an hour of
discomfort so that the other
23 hours feel better that's a good trade
true like i i like that trade
i don't have to love the gym i have to
love
what it makes me feel for the other 23
hours
and for me i boil my life down to a set
of fundamental criteria
that really boils down to a small set of
things that if i
tick those boxes each day life's going
to be pretty good so one of those
criteria
is two great hours of
meaningful work on something that i
really want to create or
or do that's not phone calls and emails
and whatever that's like
meaningful work on something i'm making
something i'm creating
yeah movement is
another one of my criteria and the cool
thing about criteria
the way i think about them is that you
can
you can chunk up or you can niche down
so like if you take
i could have said when it comes to
movement like my favorite
activities are boxing or brazilian jiu
jitsu i love both
but here's the problem with like you can
you can say every day i need to box or
every day i need to do brazilian jiu
jitsu in order to feel good
but you always have to be aware that
what that's giving you is
is if you chunk up something more
abstract
it gives you a feeling of whatever it
may be like for example if you are
someone who dances
every day what do you love about dancing
they'll often say the same types of
things i love getting into my body i
love that
feeling of getting out of my head i love
that feeling of
freedom that comes when i do that of
abandon i love
the creativity i love the you know
connecting with something
like music or there's something bigger
going on there
than the movements in salsa dancing
right and it's really important to
remember that because
when you chunk up you realize that
your criteria are quite simple and there
are thousands of ways to meet each
criteria
and in i haven't been able to do
brazilian jiu jitsu in
a year and a half now for a year because
of the pandemic
i need to be able to chunk up to
what this gives me and then chunk back
and then niche down again to
something specific that allows me to
fulfill that in a different way
whether it's boxing whether it's
training at the gym whether it's getting
into running or whatever just saying
movement
so like breaking it down the movement
you like so you're
so like the fundamental is movement but
then you're like i like these
things but i can kind of go over here
with it or there
and if you said to me today matt uh do
you want to go on a hike
and i said ah but i was gonna box today
uh-huh it's good to be able to switch it
out and be like well this still ticks
that criteria for me
sure so as long as if i see my day
as a kind of uh every day
it's about did i actually do these
fundamental things
in some form you know i i need some form
of connection every day
one day it might be calling my mom a
different day it might be spending some
quality time
with a friend and having a meaningful
conversation differently
so there's different ways to meet that
every day but i do know every day
i need some form of connection i know
that
every day i need uh like
to absorb something if i can
whether new information new learning now
that could be from a podcast it could be
from a book it could be from a
conversation but
i need to feel like i'm absorbing
something new
and if you add up all of these criteria
it only amounts to four or five six
maybe things
and if i wake up every day and and say
okay my day's full but
i'm only achieving one of my criteria in
all of that
which is what happens when we get way
out of balance
i was just gonna say total imbalance
right and that's happened to me before
where i'm achieving an extraordinary
amount in my work and deeply unhappy
and that's because my
full being isn't being
expressed but the danger in life is that
if a certain part of your criteria
gives you a ton of validation you can
get addicted to it
so if your work is something that you
know
every day you do it and it keeps giving
you accolades
and trophies and attention and everyone
comes up to you and says it's amazing
what you did
like that thing why are you talking
about me why are you just
looking at me and saying these things to
me
i'm just kidding i mean but it's not
really it was my old life but i mean i
i fortunately it didn't have to be my
existence it dominated my time but by no
means was my means to an end
but what we get the most validation for
validation creates mutation and
whatever we whatever people feed our ego
on
is often the thing that becomes mutated
in our life
you see that physically with people who
are obsessed with the gym and you get
the guy with the why are you still
talking about me
in every way you see it and that like
but you said something interesting i
heard
where you said you were asked about race
car driving
and you said i didn't love it
that's exactly in line with what
i'm talking about here because you
didn't
if you stopped there people might get
the wrong impression they might get the
impression oh so she was never happy she
never enjoyed it
no what was important was what you said
after that
so you said i it i didn't love it
there were aspects of it i loved yeah
that's right right i
it allowed me to set a goal and achieve
that goal it allowed me to
have something to focus on to master to
yeah
so what you're really describing there
is not
this answer to your happiness prayers in
racing
it's something that for a time allowed
me to meet some of my criteria
yeah yeah that's so wow thank you for
like unpacking me right there
that's true i mean that makes sense that
there's just like
yes the the there was certain aspects or
criteria within that job
that were fulfilling me and um
yes there was an imbalance probably
because there wasn't enough sort of
aspects or buckets to
like in the day but um but that's why i
could keep doing it too
we can use anything as a means to like
you said
through movement you could be doing jiu
jitsu you could be doing hiking you
could
there's tons of ways to do movement
right so there's tons of ways to set a
goal and accomplish it and for me
it was very like racing was that thing
for so long
amongst many others but um but but that
that makes perfect sense
and i wish that everyone could hear you
say that because
it i honestly think that is one of the
most important messages
hearing from you someone who has
achieved on an extraordinary
level on something that you know
a has so many fans but b would be seen
whether by fans or not as a kind of like
situation where someone's found their
calling
i think for people to hear that
is an incredible pressure valve and
incredibly necessary because we have
this myth of the calling
you know we're always uh like people say
to me matt you found your calling i'm
like no i haven't
i found something that meets my criteria
there are a hundred of those
there's many like and by the way there
will be many
my life is gonna evolve and it's gonna
change direction and i'm gonna
in 10 years i'll be speaking about other
things new things i'll have evolved
so i don't want anyone to come along and
tell me i've found my calling because
that pigeon holes me
i want to you know don't reduce me to to
one thing
that i'm not that simple but we have a
society that
especially these days is all about
follow your passion follow your calling
follow
find your purpose and it's it sounds
like it's motivational talk
but i actually think it's the opposite
because it it freaks people out
it freaks them out when they don't know
what their passion is
it freaks them out when they have many
passions and they're like so i'm
supposed to just
do one thing like this is this has to be
the be all endless of who i am on this
earth i have many things i love
it freaks people out when they look at
other people and who are really
successful and think
have a false impression of what that
thing is like they're living their bliss
because they've found their calling and
their purpose and they're just
and it's just not like that i know
people see me on stage at my retreat
and i know they're i know for a fact
because people come to and they're like
i want to do what you do
and i'm like what is it you think i do
like well i want to like you on stage
and i want to be there
well guess what my retreat happens twice
a year yeah
it's a byproduct of six days so that
means
12 days of 365 days of the year
are me on stage doing that the most of
the rest of my year
is me at home on a laptop
like running a team remotely through
zoom
that's most of my year you
if you say i want to be a speaker that's
actually a very different path than what
i do
because speaking is this much of what i
do and then there's one being a ceo of a
company and then there's
all these different things managing a
team and
we have these false perceptions and i
genuinely
loved when you said that because i was
like everyone needs to hear this because
they would take some pressure off
themselves and say
a thousand things could be my thing my
job is not to find
my one true calling my job is to do a
thing
and to make sure that it's a thing
that meets some of my criteria
and as i go to try and craft that thing
to meet more of my criteria because it's
a sculpting process
it's kind of it's like it's almost like
a little bit of a parallel to
a person uh to to who you are as a
person it's like
i was i felt so fortunate that in my
career i was able to show
all these different like aspects of
myself as a person where i was like
you know i'm the girl on a cover of a
magazine and it's
you know i'm in a swimsuit or i'm you
know giving a speech
or i'm you know in this in my ra you
know racing and hardcore
or you know there's so many different
ways and i could kind of i
i was able to show all these different
sides of me and i was
always trying to remind people that
they're all me like don't think that i
just have to be this race car
driver like i'm all these other things i
want to be funny i want to be cool i
want to be smart i want to be
i want to learn i want to be sexy i want
to like there's all these other aspects
of me
and um it's similar that you know why
can't we
why do we have to be one thing why do
you always just have to be matt the
relationship guy
what if you want to be mata
the guy talking about what we're talking
about today because
you know people ask me a lot of dating
questions we haven't we're having a
great conversation and it's
we're not talking about dating for any
of it yet you know we might that's fine
but
so far anyone who knows me
online as the dating guy for the last 20
minutes
has suddenly realized oh wow
he's got more to say and it's actually
important
the world will constantly try to
put you in a narrative because we like
things to be simple
that's true we want narratives we don't
have to continually adjust to
we want to say ability yeah this
person's that that person's that or
whatever like it's
easy and also by the way it doesn't
affect our identity
if someone stays in their place this is
a whole other concept
fascinated by but like yeah if someone
huh
the moment you change something about
yourself
it affects everyone that knows you not
just it
you could affect them in a positive way
where they get inspired by it but it
could all equally make them feel like
well wait hang on you stay in your place
why is danica patrick talking about
health and wellness and what it like why
don't you just stick to this thing she
knows
but when we do that
it's there's a kind of insecurity we
have
that if they switched gears and if
they're talking about something else
then maybe my
story about like i have to stick in my
lane is not true but then
then i'd have to be brave enough to step
out of my lane and do something
different i don't want to do that so i'd
rather believe that we're sort of
on our set paths and we tend
to critiqu critique someone
and bash them until they get enough
credibility
to where it no longer is productive to
bash them because we're now like
well they're too far gone like they you
know
i'm sure there was a day where people
looked at joe rogan and were like
why is he who does he think he is like a
radio show host or something like
he's this isn't he should stick to you
know fighting and comedy like this isn't
his thing and what
and of course there's a certain point
where it becomes undisputable
that well he's like one of the biggest
podcasters in the entire world so
it to me i see this like um
to me it's like uh we see this in our
society so much with people that
um have to change their belief systems
maybe it's religious
maybe it's political whatever it is um
or or even just be open-minded is that
they tend to have this
sort of regimented cognitive dissonance
with their own world that they're not
able to think differently because as
soon as they look at
one of those foundational aspects of
their life
differently then to me i describe it
like it's like a house of cards as soon
as you pull one of those bottom cards
out
then all the or maybe it's even looking
at the government like questioning
things
that outside of you but as soon as you
sort of take your belief structure
or something that you believe about
somebody else and pull that card out
what does it mean and so for me it means
that
you have new now you have accountability
for your life
and that you could change it that you're
in charge of it that it could look
different that you might have to
that you have to you have to see
yourself in a whole new way and that's a
lot of work
it's a lot of work it's very scary
to change our mind about things is is
effort
and and it's even more effort and more
scary when we have built our identity
around those things that we believe
right because it leaves us with an
existential problem
of if i don't believe this then who am i
if i'm not someone who's
like who's really good at this thing and
that's what they do
then who am i you know i i i remember
making a conscious decision
i started what i do at an unhealthy age
to start what i do
you know i was 20 years younger i was
unhealthy
uh admired for having lots of answers
is a very dangerous thing and then
that's all the girls that you
psychoanalyzed along the way i'm just
kidding
those that that's been okay it'd be it'd
be harder if i
had built an army of men who were who
were men
sorry i don't i i
i got a lot of attention at an early age
for having answers
and being good at it how old are you now
33.
the danger of that is that your
validation becomes your mutation right
i now say i'm getting a lot of attention
and a lot of support and a lot of
validation for being
right about things that can easily
send you down a path of thinking my
whole life now
who knows anything at 21 right i knew
some things
but clearly had so much to learn
so it's a very dangerous thing to get
attached to the identity of having the
answers at an age where you should be
open and exploring and asking lots of
questions and trying to absorb
and i remember getting to a point in my
20s where i
i said i can be one of two things going
forward
i can either be the
guru type who like keeps having all the
answers
and keeps knowing you know you ask me a
question i've always got the answer
i could be that or i can increasingly
show my flaws what i'm worried about
what i'm insecure about what i'm
struggling with what i'm trying to learn
and and let people see that because
that's a more a that's a more
sustainable personality
you know like that that's something i
can grow with that
allows me to grow and b um
it's i'm not constantly needing to play
like i know what i don't know
it's cleaner i can just know what i know
and not know what i don't know and
sometimes not even be sure of what i
know
when someone gets attached to their
identity their opinions their
you know their way of thinking it's very
stifling
and letting go of it we want to know why
people find it hard
you're wrong you're clearly wrong how do
you continue to believe this
we don't we we're very quick to look at
the facts of someone's beliefs but we
don't
look at beliefs in the same
conversations as needs
and you have to look at both in the same
conversation
because it's so many beliefs have
nothing to do with facts they just have
to do with needs
this
you know you can have someone
politically who thinks
who needs something in order to feel
better than everybody else
i need to align with this party or this
belief system because it makes me feel
righteous
it's just like grand scale codependency
well it's like i
there's no nuance now in an argument
because your argument isn't about
seeking truth it's about feeling better
than everybody else
you're you know we get people who attach
themselves to
some religious beliefs where it's just
about security as opposed to whether
that particular idea about a religion or
makes any sense it's about i i need to
feel secure and this thing makes me feel
secure and we
rarely evaluate the needs that underpin
beliefs
that make people believe something and
make it very hard to give up
something that's not
what i think we all have to do for
ourselves is
look at what am i going to attach my
importance to or what am i going to
attach my significance to
if i attach my significance to being
right then
i'm not going to take many risks to be
wrong
and that's going to make my life smaller
if i attach like i like to attach
my some of my significance to just
looking for truth
and if i attach significance but if
that's your if that's the case then
if i say something today where i'm like
i said that but i don't really agree
with it
i don't know why i said it i i'm annoyed
that i said it
i'm instead of being like having to
pretend like i do think that was the
right thing and defend it
i could just be like you know i said
this thing on the danica patrick
interview which
actually i don't even agree with and she
made a she actually made a better point
about this and that's what i'm going to
believe from now on because i actually
think she's more right about that than i
am
wasn't that simply just being
open-minded
it's yeah but in order to be open-minded
you do have to let go of certain
attachments
i have to let go of that need to be yes
to be right right all the time or to
validate what you think is right
yeah and if i think like it even comes
down to my relationship with my audience
if i say do i want a relationship with
my audience where
i teach them that i'm right all the time
or do i want to have an identity with
them that says hey i'm matthew
hussey i am probably going to get it
wrong a lot
but i promise you i'm always going to be
looking for the most truthful answer to
your problems and the things you're
struggling with and i'll tell you my
most truthful answer at the time
and if at any point yeah i get better
information
i'm happy to to discredit anything i've
ever said
to give you a better version of what i
know today if
i have that relationship with my
audience then
my now like i can truly be powerful
because i can
they know they can trust what i'm saying
they don't know to that
they can trust what i'm saying is always
right but they know it's always the
truth for me at that moment
sure and they know that at any point
i'll revise anything i've said
if my significance comes from that now
we have a route to true mastery
where have you learned these great sort
of insights actually let me back up i
want to ask about
ego first because it feels like
a lot of this has to do with the
relationship with the ego which would be
the
you know that part of us that wants to
be right needs to be right
validated you know i love the whole
saying like you know the
the the ego is impatient because it
knows its time is limited but the soul
is
patient because it knows it has forever
so you know
what what what is the role of it and how
do we work with it because i think it
has a function
um a great function um but
it it can override so many things so
what's the role of the ego
that's such a big question i i'm i'm
still
kind of playing with this idea because
perfect your truth right now my yeah
because my you know
i have a boxing trainer martin snow who
whenever i'm
whenever i'm in the ring one of his
favorite phrases is kill your ego
because he's like you the moment you get
in the ring and you're sparring
and you see a person
who is has better technique than you or
is bigger than you or is
faster than you or whatever that's ego
like you're immediately sort of bringing
your ego into the equation
he said you're not fighting a person
you're fighting a style mm-hmm
he said so forget the powers your
insecurity peaks up
to counteract the attack on your ego of
like i'm the best oh wait their
techniques better
and it's a response yeah like i'm
putting myself
in competition with a person instead of
just being like
i'm not fighting a person i'm fighting a
style you know and
and he would always say to me kill your
ego and the moment i would start to
in boxing you burn a lot of energy just
in the way you you tense up and you
breathe
especially when you're when you have a
real prospect of getting hit the body
suddenly starts working differently than
when you're hitting a bag
you have a lot more energy hitting a bag
than hitting a person because
you're not there's no fear involved the
moment you're in a ring and now all of a
sudden there's the adrenaline and
there's the fear and there's that
you're like you're burning a lot of
energy just just tensing up and
that's why you could put two people in a
ring and
the you can have a boxing trainer who is
far more out of shape than the person
there
they're coaching like i got some of my
boxing trainers have been incredibly out
of shape
right they're like you know one of
martin is like a guy in his 50s who's
like you know he's not training every
day he's not like
he's out of shape but he'll still run
rings around me because he's more
relaxed
because he's he's not like tensing up in
the ring i'm burning all of this energy
an analogy for like a resistance when
you like with
certain things emotionally or mentally
it's like you know
sort of attachment creates resistance
it's sort of like
almost similarly like the ego creates
the resistance that's right and that's
where the ego is the enemy
and and you know for me on stage it's a
similar thing
yeah yeah here goes the enemy it
on stage i like i i think
what really helps me when to shed stage
fright
is instead of thinking i need to look
cool on stage
just thinking i really care about these
people
and i want to i actually want them to
i want to try in the time i have with
them to give them as many things as i
can
that can help them and when i think
about it like that
i don't think about it in terms of
looking good i think about it in terms
of making an impact
and that immediately dissolves so
much of the fear associated with when i
go on tour
getting on stage there's always some
nerves it's not like i shed my nerves
completely but
i know that if i'm too nervous it's
because i've made it all about me
and i therefore think that
ego is a very dangerous thing but
there's a friend of mine who always
jokes he's like i want to write a book
called
you know jamison jordan who films my
content
he always jokes he's like yeah but i
want to write a book called in defense
of ego
oh because i i like think that ego is
kind of important sometimes and it is
and i and i and i wonder about that
because ego does make okay so the good
role so now let's
let's literally vet that out on that
side of it right so you just like
said kill the ego now like in defense of
the ego
what would you say or what would he say
i think that uh i mean look ego's been
responsible for an enormous
amount of my achievement in my life a
lot of the things that now give
me and my family security
and and financial independence and a
better life
have come from a well
i i tell a lie they started from a place
of real insecurity
like i i don't i want my family to be
okay i want us to be able to
you know i don't want us to have
financial problems later on and so there
was a lot of that for me at the
beginning real survival stuff
but once survival is no longer the
the game because you know yeah
everything's not burning down and you
look around and you're like okay
everyone's okay now
that's where ego starts to to come in
and say yeah but
we could be here and i think that
there's
a lot of things i've done because of the
excitement of
if i create this thing it's going to be
really great and
there's some of the intention is it's
going to help people
and some of the intention is it's also
going to make me look really good
because i've
you know said it really well you know
i've crafted an amazing speech i've
written an amazing book there's you know
i'd be lying if
i said there wasn't some element of that
in there when you write a great chat
but that that's the interplay between
ego and intention
because for me so powerful when i write
it's the whole point in my opinion well
i think yeah i think the intention that
i the intention of wanting to help the
people correct in the audience
versus the uh ego
going like i'm on stage i'm the guy
right like the intention of wanting to
be the guy
that's right is you want to help people
but you got to be the guy to help people
yeah i think though i always think about
it in terms of a car
ego oh i'm sure i'll get this then
[Applause]
i didn't craft this specifically for you
you must be sick of car metal
i no i think they're great i think about
it in terms of
there's in the car at all times is
my best intentions and my ego
they're both in the car i'd never fully
get ego out of the car
but the seats in the car matter
so when i start writing a
a chapter of a book or when i start
crafting a speech
the intention is i i know this is a
concept people really need to hear
like i know this is something people or
even like if i make a weekly video i've
been making
a new weekly video for nine years now
every time i make a video it starts from
a place of before every video i ask the
same question i usually have a crisis
right before a video where i've crafted
it or scripted it all and then i get
right before the video and i'm like
this video sucks oh my god and i'll look
at jameson and i'll be like
why why are we even doing this video but
that question's really girls want to
know
okay the girls want to know well and the
guys need to no no i'm just kidding
but it always does come down to
that that question sounds at the time
silly but it's
actually the most important question is
okay we've done all the work
we've scripted this video and what we
want it to be a bounce on
why does this video even need to exist
like why is it important we do this
video and if we can't answer that
question well
it's a problem it means we're actually
not aligned do you
have times where you can't answer it huh
do you ever have times where you can't
answer it or do you always have an
answer for it
there are times where i think it's it
rarely means we don't do the video what
it often means
is ah you know what it's we've been
making about all of this stuff
at its core it's about this
you know if we're doing a video about
like um
what to do uh
you know what to do when he ghosts you
right
let's take that right what to do when he
ghosts you
now on its surface it's like
really we have to make a video about
this like
i don't the ghosting is a very term i am
bored of you know but but then when you
boil it down and say
well hang on like why do we need to do
this
well when you like someone
at its core what's the problem with
ghosting it's that you like someone
you had hopes for what it might be
and then not only does it not turn out
to be that
but it leaves you with this horrible
sense that
you're not even important enough for
someone to communicate with
that you know what's
what is wrong with me that someone
wouldn't even think
to and maybe i'll never know maybe
there's something deeply wrong with me
and i'll never even know what it is we
have anger towards the person but really
it's like this deep hurt
and this fear of i i'm worthless
i am worthless i couldn't keep the
person
i couldn't even get a baseline level of
decency like i'm
we don't if we're if ghosting is
troubling us
it's different to be like wow that
person's that person ghosted me i don't
want them in my life
that's one thing but when it's troubling
us
we know that it's not to do with them
because if it's just to do with them you
just go well i just don't want them in
my life
right but why is it sticking with me
it's sticking with me because i it's
it's really made me question my own
value
and so if we get to that video which on
the surface the title makes it sound
like
a you know like surface
level silly dating advice video what to
do when he ghosts you
but if right before the video i sit with
jameson and i go
why do we need to make this video and
we say you know what we need to make
this video because
this actually beneath all of the like
silly conversations that we have with
friends and whatever when someone ghosts
us and
i hate this person what an idiot blah
blah blah beneath all of that
is like real pain is it people are
actually suffering because it's made
them question their own value
this isn't a video about ghosting this
is a video about reminding people of
their value
all right now i'm making the video a
reframe
and you also have connected with
emotions the core of what this thing is
about
i you know that did you see the film
inception
love love that film there's a there's a
moment in that movie that's
it's so important which
and spoiler alert go forward five
minutes in this interview if you don't
you haven't watched
the point right it's it game now yeah
there's a moment where they're trying to
get this guy to make a different
decision
they need to go into his dreams into his
subconscious and get him to make a
decision that he wasn't going to make
and the decision is you know he has this
huge monopoly
on an industry and they need him to
break up the business so that
uh it doesn't become a corrupting
influence in the world
and they're trying to figure out how do
we infiltrate this guy's brain
to get him to make this decision and the
way they do it
is they say we need to tap into the
deepest well of emotion that this guy
has
the relationship with his father and
what they realize is
if they can go into his subconscious and
convince him
that his father deep down
who and he all he wants really in life
is for his dad to be proud of him
that deep down his father more than
anything else
more than wanting him to be this great
business tycoon
would be most proud of him if
he went on his own journey and did
things his way
if we can convince him of that then that
will be the thing that makes him break
up the company
and so that's what they do now that's
tapping into the deepest why
that's available to that guy
now the reason i say all of this is
because
when i go to make a video and i'm asking
these kinds of questions
that boils things down to the purest of
intentions
now let's say i make the video and
because it came from
such an authentic place and because i
really connected with the concept and
because i did it really well
it goes viral and because it goes viral
thousands and thousands of people are
commenting and going oh my god this
video is amazing this
and more than that they're going this
man is a genius
right not just the video is amazing this
man is a genius
i love they're sharing they're tagging
friends i love this guy
you have to watch his videos all of that
now
is not feeding necessarily intention
but eager and where intention was
driving the car
to get that video made somewhere without
me realizing it
ego took the wheel and intention is now
a passenger how do i know
because i'm nervous about the next video
so it's cyclical well
the success of this has made me go i'm
really nervous about the next one now
because people really loved this one
i got to make it either better or at
least really good too
now i know intention intention is now a
passenger
or is maybe not even a passenger in the
front seat maybe intention is now in the
backseat
and ego is driving and i know because
i'm nervous
much more nervous than i was a week
before what changed not my ability to
make a great video
what changed is all the attention that i
got and and the weight things people
said so when it comes to defense of
ego
i i think that at some point in our life
we probably can all point to something
that we achieved or did
where the result came we did something
quite difficult
or quite amazing in some cases because
of ego
yeah the
i perhaps perhaps the answer is that as
we
get wiser
we realize that ego as a fuel
is a really toxic fuel because no matter
what i achieve it will never be
satisfied it's insatiable so
it's more about consciously saying i'm
gonna let
good intention pure intention be the
fuel
and you still have fuel it's just a
cleaner burning fuel
than ego and that's what i'm trying to
do these days is recognize that whilst
the ego has created a lot of good
things in my life not just ego by the
way still good intentions but
you know a contaminated mix of the two
that more and more i want good intention
pure intention to be in the driving seat
i think that personally i think that
uh all information is carrying frequency
and it's through that intention and
through
the purity of it and how clean it is
is the frequency like people can feel
like people can feel that resonant
frequency so the information coming out
of their mouth
it's like what i use like the infra you
going to work and you're like i hate my
boss screw this
i just uh i don't want to see him and
you walk in he walks in and
oh hey bud good to see you oh man yeah
nice to see you how was your weekend
and like the frequency underneath is a
lie it's a big fat
lie and so we're having this there's
like
a c mass confusion it's the mask
of mass confusion that the information
coming out of us doesn't always resonate
with the frequency that is
truly there and so we feel the frequency
even though we don't know we're feeling
that
i agree but that's why so i if i'm gonna
guess or use my you know
information in my head about all of
these different concepts
is that's why your videos hit is because
you connect with the intention
so the frequency of the information is
resonating with people so not only they
get good information
but they feel it too i 1000
agree and for anyone out there because
we
we do register it when someone sounds
when there's a fakeness
and inauthenticity we we register it on
some
strange level i always
i would actually say in all of the
videos i've ever done
there's always been an authenticity
but fear played too much of a part in
the early stages
of you know
wanting to sound a certain way wanting
to be perceived a certain way and that
was all fear talking and
and the older i've gotten and i've got a
long way to go but the
the more i the more i become a bit like
i don't know what the word i i become a
bit like ah [ __ ] it
yes like oh my god my sayings oh well oh
well right
yeah [ __ ] it oh well it's the same i i
kind of think
you know what i just i come to this
podcast video interview whatever
thinking
you rolled up today and said [ __ ] it oh
well however this goes
in sort of yeah you know i come and i'm
just like
whatever you ask me i am just gonna
be the most be yourself sounds very
trite
and i i'm wary of that advice because i
think it's not
being yourself isn't the same as like
you still want to bring your best
you still want to try your hardest at
something being yourself isn't like
go ahead danica like ask away whatever
you want i'm just going to lay back in
my chair and be myself it's like no i
still want to lean into the conversation
and give my best but
but i really want to to just answer in a
way that
makes me walk away feeling good about me
you know what's so funny is that
i norm i mean i always do prep before
every interview and
um and so i did some of course
but normally i would come up with you
know
two pages of just kind of like general
questions and then i kind of organize my
thoughts and i have a flow
and i at least have an outline for what
i want to ask
and you know i know your work so well
because i've watched so many
videos and um and but there's also so
many different
sort of aspects that of exis of like
the human experience that you could
speak to
and so i kind of didn't even know where
to start i was like i'm just gonna trust
the flow of this
i'm just gonna like i could show you i
have like five things written on the
notepad
and i'm like you know what i'm just
gonna trust that
we're gonna sit down and it's just gonna
come out and it's just gonna flow and
thank god because
you know what i feel as though you're in
a transition
where i'm glad that i didn't come up
with
tell me the three things that we should
look out for when it comes to
so i met you and you met me like we
literally met each other
right where right at the same place i
think that's a very interesting thing
it's really interesting and i am so i
feel very grateful that you did that
because i definitely am in a transition
i definitely am i
i you know it
it's weird i uh about
i want to say i hit like 28
and i when i was 27 i i had a moment
like a little crisis moment where i was
like probably
not a little crisis moment that's me
underplaying it i had a crisis moment
where i was like i'm
not this should feel better than than it
does like i'm i'm i'm really like i
could
literally take off so many of the things
that at 21 i would have said like
these are the things you know whether
it's like be a new york times bestseller
or like
do tours around the world live in
america that was like a dream was the
idea of like living
in the states and i just
something wasn't right and
i sort of slowed down
like tried to take stock more and
re-evaluate things and i actually
mellowed a decent amount for yeah you
only got
exponentially more popular well the
funny thing is
i over the last year and a half to two
years
i i felt
newly inspired and
that's been challenging because oh in
what way
because i've taken on so much again
and like my inspiration is like oh i'm
like
i got so many ideas and i got like i
really feel like
there's so much i'm excited to talk
about right now and there's so much i'm
excited saying
it makes me go yeah let me do this let
me let me write another book
let me do it let me take on this list
and before i know it
i'm i've sort of wedged myself back into
a place of insanity
where there's so much going on and so
much and are you
energized or are you tired well
energized
but it
see it's really difficult because it's
easy for it's easy to take on a ton of
things because you're inspired
yeah right but then you
you can get to you know guy winch
a friend of mine he talked he talked to
me and said like
because i was saying to guy i was like
guy i don't know if you know guy
an amazing therapist
and i remember saying to guy like guy
i'm i'm like
i need to figure out how to like
i should be enjoying more like this is
really amazing i want to enjoy it and i
i'm taking on so much and i'm loving my
work but i'm also like
i'm stressed like i'm really stressed
and he had this great concept that i
want to make sure everyone knows this is
guys concept not mine
i love that you're mentioning a
therapist and you're basically a
therapist
all right well i'm a different i'm a
different
uh line of work but i i actually believe
crediting is extremely important i know
soft
subject but i just i think one of the
worst traits of the internet right now
is the lack of credit that goes to
people for the things they say
that people are so quick to um to take
something and just
speak it without talking about where
they got it from or who
without attributing i think it's very
poor form um
but but guy actually said to me you know
everyone has this
subjective kind of bar above which
everything becomes overwhelming
below which things are more enjoyable
sure and the problem is if you go above
that bar even a little bit even the
things that you previously enjoyed
can suddenly start being corrupted by
the overwhelm and the stress you have
and you stop enjoying even the things
that were enjoying
he said sometimes just bringing things
not
it's not about like take six months off
and go to india
and meditate it's about bringing things
just below the bar
if you're a bit above the bar bring
things just below the bar again
and you'll know when you're below it
because you'll feel it you'll feel
differently
and my tendency is when i feel good i'm
so extreme
like i'm too extreme i have a problem
like i
do the name of this podcast it's called
pretty pretty so i get it i get it there
are times when i'd be worthy of that
title
but i i'm it's so extreme like i'll be
like
i'll wake up on a saturday and i'll be
like i'm so glad i've got the whole day
free like
because the last five days will have
been in sunny and i'll be like i've got
the whole weekend i'm just
not gonna plan anything i'm just gonna
enjoy the weekend
and then i'll be like i
kind of feel like training today i'm
going to go train today and all that
same day call up a trainer and i'll be
like
let's that very same day yeah you're so
excited that you have the same day
time off probably an hour later i'll be
like
do you have any training so yeah okay i
booked that in five o'clock
maybe i should like go on a hike yeah
and then i'll be a nice relaxing
afternoon you know what i'm gonna clear
out the garage
i've been meaning to do that and then
before i know it i have booked a
like this manic day
and i this kind of sounds like something
i might do
yeah and i look at that and i'm i have
to remind and i have people around me
that know me very very well and they're
like are you
watching yourself like this is it's very
easy
for me to suddenly go above that bar
again because i'm feeling good
right i start to like over subscribe
every part of my life
to the point where it's above the bar
and now what happens is you're in danger
of a crash
now there's a kind of especially in our
line of work where you
have attention and you have validation
and you ha and there's lots of like
stimulation there's a sort of
speedy feeling to it all
that can get you running for quite a
long time
at a ridiculous intensity because it's
got this like speedy edge to it
but you're always in danger of like
once you hit a level of like
everything short circuits and now i'm
like
cancel everything i don't want to do it
like this is all too much
i can't turn into a giant [ __ ] and
nobody
nobody's safe around you i'm sorry
that's what i do
you do that i get quiet i get very
quietly
everyone's like yeah i get i sometimes
well usually before events i get i'm so
loud on stage but before an event i'm so
quiet people come up to me and if
they've just started working for me
they'll be like is he is he okay is he
is there something wrong and everyone
who knows me would be like no he's fine
he's just
that are you like organizing your
thoughts or are you
i don't hit max because
it's cause i i get i know i so badly
want to do a good job
that i just kind of get very insular
yeah it can be insular
it can be ego and but
i'm i'm always having to
manage that thing and that's what i'm
trying to the reason i say i'm in
transition is because
i i am
my biggest goal in my life right now or
i would
let me say this i the most important
goal in my life right now
is learning to really
feel connected to everything as i do it
instead of instead of just like
adding because it's like more more more
let me just you know let me help more
people let me do this let me do that how
do you make sure you're connected then
i think if i'm how do you know you are
because how do you know well i
i didn't what did i do i i
did a slot on entertainment tonight a
few weeks ago
and we were driving back from
entertainment tonight and
i was with jameson and uh
he said to me we were we were on our way
back to the house and he
i was like i said out loud like what
else do i need to do today
and i was like i had the adrenaline and
i don't
love tv because i just it's
i actually i don't know i find it hard
to focus on things for the rest of the
day once i come off tv
i sort of have this adrenaline and it
just i don't know it tires me out
but we were on our way home and uh
and i said i was like what do i need to
do today and he goes
well i'll tell you what we need to do we
still have that video that we need to
shoot for next weekend so we're going to
go home and shoot that
i wanted to murder him maybe i was going
to say you're like
i really like i felt so mad irrationally
mad
i like wanted i was like so great and i
suddenly turned
so grumpy oh my god so grumpy and i was
like
it went above the bar yep and so
for me the recognition of that is
okay i know that i am
this is a whatever i'm doing right now
there is a pace there is a pressure
there is a deadline i put on myself
[Music]
that is now detaching me from how
wonderful everything actually is
and the whilst my ego doesn't want to
give me an easier deadline doesn't want
to
tell me that this thing i really want to
do today has to now be done later
because it's one too many things whilst
my ego doesn't want to hear that
my happiness my sense of enjoyment
actually does need a different pace in
order for
all of this to
in order for me to keep doing a good job
frankly
like when i started out and it was about
survival
sometimes there's a pace that's
determined by
survival mode sure and you do things a
different one
yeah you do things for a time that you
wouldn't do for a lifetime because we
need to
get out of this situation and i've felt
that
but what has taken me time
and still i find catches up with me
is remembering that you're no longer
surviving
that no it's okay
nothing's burning down you're all right
the lion is chasing you
yeah we're not in survival you're okay
you can
no need for fomo yeah just like
just do it don't i enjoy this i'm not
going back on what i said earlier about
i don't think it's always fun
but enjoyment to me isn't fun enjoy you
can enjoy hard things you can enjoy
things that are a struggle
because you're you're enjoying
challenging yourself
if that has been sucked out of it
and all that's left is this to-do list
that makes you want to strangle
everybody
it's because something's broken and i
have
i have done that to myself over and over
again
and the reason i talk about i think you
were talking too was it alanis
morris oh i did yeah yeah i saw that i
saw a piece of that interview that was
really interesting to me
where she said she said something about
like being the timid
like in inside she's like a timid puppy
uh-huh
but outside there's this angry like
aggressive like take charge
and she said that often what we speak
about the most is the counterpart to
what we feel and
there is no doubt that
uh outside of the dating realm
one of the subjects i've been most
passionate about is
the uh ability to
enjoy things to um
to love the journey to not become
overwhelmed
uh by how many different things that
you've got going on or the
size of the problem that's there in your
life
a lot of that has been because in my
lifetime i have experienced
those things an awful lot and
i'm always talking to myself on some
level maybe not there are some videos
where i'm solving a problem that gets
put to me a lot and i'm solving that
problem
but but there's so much of
you know i i don't i never make any
bones about it like
everything when i talk to people about
self-love
i'm passionate about that subject
because i
am well aware of what tyrant i am to
myself
when i'm not practicing what i preach
there self-love is so necessary for me
because i'm terrible to myself it's like
i
love to sort of share the perspective i
have that you know when you see someone
that you look up to whether they be a
guru or
a leader of some kind spirituality
whatever it may be
a coach if they're going through a
struggle in that very
aspect i'm like of course they are why
do you think they're interested in the
subject
yeah you don't become passionate about
something because you just like
it's like it's not because it's not
something you're not
dealing with correct and so yeah
i think it's it's important for people
to understand that they
should be thank god that you gave
yourself permission
to be that vulnerable guy so what i hear
now
like i'm curious then because it
seems so natural to just take it from
like okay so
you know how do you be in relationships
blah blah blah blah and so go
what are you actually dealing with now
and you're dealing with transitions so
then
so for me i think the most applicable
thing that it seems like
you could share from sort of a coaching
aspect would be what would you say to
people
as far as you know call it red flags or
whatever you want to
you know use the use terminology that
you'd make a video but what where
what are the signs that you
are ready or a transition is calling you
because it feels like while you're in it
you're kind of you got the signs
so because there's a lot of people in
that position i think that we've come
off of a year
that's just been overwhelming
underwhelming hard and you know there's
a lot of transitionings happening
transitions happening um but then
there's just
natural ones you were falling into this
transition anyway without
pandemics without whatever else and so
sometimes these things like this can
push us over the edge but
what would you what would you say to
people as far as with from your
experience
that you would say these are the signs
that i would say to look for
that are calling you to transition
your life that's a great question
i am
we we have a mutual friend lewis howes
yeah and uh
in at the end of 2019
i got a text from him in december saying
me and a small group of people have got
this really fortunate opportunity to go
and spend
five days with wim hof just in a group
of like 10 of us
which you know wim hof has blown up and
hundreds of people go to his events and
so on he was like we have a really
unique opportunity just as
ten of us to spend five days with him
going through
this extreme kind of cold exposure i'm
so cold right now i could not imagine
going to wim hof right now i'm like all
right danica
i see me shivering i this is not
something that i would ever want to do
like i'm not i'm not a thrill seeker in
that way
okay like i have i'm adventurous in my
own way but
that's not my idea of like i need to go
and prove
that i can sit in the ice for 10 minutes
straight
up to my neck or that i can climb the
tallest mountain in czechoslovakia and
nothing but my shorts i
like that's not something i would want
to do
and yet something in that moment lewis
texted me and i was like
okay say yes and that
to me was a sign because
it wasn't something i wanted to do but
in my head
i thought i'd been through a difficult
year
and i thought anything that
shakes my life up right now in an
interesting or challenging way
is a good thing in other words talking
about criteria
it wasn't about finding the perfect
thing it was just being like
the thing that was needed was shake up
this fit the bill i was like this is
going to be hard for me and i don't
associate it's not like i associate with
being
wonderful in the cold like oh i'm going
to be naturally good at this
no i am going to be bad at this like
this is not my idea of a good time i
don't like cold water
i've never liked cold water period like
if someone's like let's get in the pool
it's a bit chilly but let's get in i'm
always like
i'm good yeah hot tub why would you let
me know
but no that's not fun to me
and so we went and it was extreme and it
was incredibly difficult and all of that
but even afterwards so it felt right i
thought
that felt somehow like a weird clumsy
move in the right direction
it felt like it it shook me up
it gave me a different challenge it
forced me to do something i wasn't good
at
it made me realize how much of my life
i'd spent doing things i was good at
um and what how limiting that can be
so i that was a good sign for me
was that on something i would normally
always say no to i thought myself
tempted to say yes and did say yes
those are interesting signs to watch out
for i think that
another sign to watch out for is when
the thing that you're really good at
that's worked for you consistently in
the past
is no longer giving you the same bang
for the buck
like it used to scratch that itch it
used to do that thing and it's like
this is not work i'm getting diminishing
returns from this thing
which i do think is often a sign that
life is out of balance
and that we can continue to blindly do
more of the same
and keep achieving in the same way we
always have but
it wasn't going to change your life to
get another trophy it wasn't going to
change your life to get another accolade
in the racing world like
now that's fine if you keep enjoying it
and your life there's other parts of
your life that you love and
all it all just kind of works in harmony
there's nothing wrong with
continuing to do that but i do think
sometimes you reach a point where you go
i'm no longer growing yeah i'm not
i i like i know this game it doesn't
mean it's easy
it's a very different it's not doesn't
mean it's easy but it's what i know
and it's what i'm comfortable with and
it's a kind of heart that i
that i'm comfortable with that i
i inhabit as home and i then start going
right now i've realized in my life like
what's necessary for this next chapter
of my life is a different
set of tools different software
um a different operating system than the
one that got me to where i am
today do you think that subconsciously
we
are aware of the old saying and i
believe it to be true
that your new life is going to cost your
old one
wow i i do kind of ins to some extent
relationships jobs locations people
i think that well i suppose i'm always
careful of extremes
because i think that if you take that
that idea to its extreme you have the
justification for you know shaving your
head and going and
living as a monk you're an extreme guy
you told me at the beginning
i don't think i'm that i don't know if
that's my
style is going to shave in my head
and living with the monks for i do it
for a week
i'll do that i've got the hairstyle for
a while though no i'm going to ask him
if i don't if i can keep my hair
i i i'm careful of extremes but i think
that
i think that we do have to look at it
and say what
you know where do i need to temper
the um like this always dominates this
thing over here always dominates whether
it's work or whether it's
could be a relationship this is the
thing that tends to be my dominant
thing my addiction my whatever
and then saying i'm gonna start
proactively investing more energy into a
different way of thinking or
this other thing over here that's going
to bring me more balance
the danger of course of the thing over
here that
is still present in your life is that if
you're not careful
it can slowly start to take hold again
or ramp up again because you might have
a comfort zone
right and you still have your addiction
to it so it's like micro dosing you
still
if you're not careful you still can get
your fix there and i think it's having
constant reminders
microdosing phases i'm just kidding i
don't know anything about microdosing
i just think apparently you do it's i
like it as a term
because i think we're always we're all
addicts
there is a like i think addiction has
this
funny stigma around drugs like
substances and people righteously love
to proclaim that
they don't do drugs i've never done
drugs or whatever and you're like
you did drugs you just did different
ones yeah you're addicted to that
terrible cycle of relationships that
you've been in you're addicted to that
that hormonal pain cycle you've been
putting yourself through for the last
however long exactly
i've watched you pick up your phone 10
times in the last 10 minutes
like we can get all righteous about yeah
but i don't have
that addiction but it's like it's all
the same thing it is
um and i i think that it's okay to
maintain certain things in your life
that
have got you to where you are but to be
to frame them differently there i have
both
a beautiful relationship with my work
and
an addict's relationship with my work
and
that doesn't mean that i okay i'm not
gonna work anymore
it it's an awareness that
i need to grow the beautiful
relationship i have with my work
and i need to be hyper aware of any time
that the addict is taking
over because that becomes avoidance
activity now it's distraction
from whatever it is i need to do over
here
that is actually going to be the point
of leverage in my life right now for
making me happier
doing this more isn't going to be
the thing that changes the game for me
now
i did it like going general you need to
go general with it and
that's quite so specific you need to
like there's muscles that are
underdeveloped
you this is an impressive muscle what
you've done over here
and you keep working it people are going
to keep commending you on what
impressive muscle it is
but you know that that idea that you're
only as strong as your weakest link if
outside of that
there is a unhappiness or there's an
anxiety or there's a
part of your life that's suffering or
your relationships are suffering because
you don't invest in them or
that that's going to be the thing that
brings down the hole
and that that i think is the thing we
have to be aware we want to be doing
what we do for a long time
like i want to be doing this in 30 years
i want to be still
out there being able to be energetic and
bring my best to the table
so i have to play the long game on on
what's gonna
bring me peace or happiness or de-stress
me because otherwise
this this thing that i do really well
will be a flame that burns out
very quickly and i would like to avoid
that
i think that's incredibly wise of you
you're very wise for 33.
it's easy to talk about it's not harder
to do but i'm working on it
and thank you for continuing to share
and grow and
to to grow and share the growth
because that's vulnerability it's
implying that you can think a new
thought that you can become
you can transition you can evolve and
it's you your
your your your fan base your followers
are going to are are on the same journey
thank you yeah thank you and you
as an interviewer by the way are
wonderful you're really
i know that it's uh how long have you
been doing this for now
like a year and a half wow well i think
you
it's safe to say you you got me talking
about things that i haven't talked about
very much
so you're great at what you're doing
good well thank you
thank you thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more please click on the subscribe
button